alors je vais vous faire vous ça vous
étonnera pas jean claude brialy je veux
faire une interview cire pompes
[Musique]
il n'a pas bougé pour le djing
l'interview cire-pompes j'aurais pu
l'appeler l'interview drucker mais je
l'appelle
mais pas désagréable avec michel si tu
nous regardes des jouets 600 fois la
puce à l'oreille de 150 fois mon père
avait raison entre 1 vous êtes quand
même aussi un immense acteur de théâtre
non je pense que je suis un immense ça
ne sert pas à ouidah khor abéché un
bruit sur moi je crois que je fais bien
mon métier que j'aime bien
alors on continue attendu cire-pompes
patron d'un théâtre des
bouffes-parisiens oui pas d'un
restaurant laurie vous réussissez tout
ce que vous touchez à l'âme vous verrez
que je voudrais tout chez
elle venir directeur
[Applaudissements]
que cet été vous allez faire deux
festivals festival d'anjou et de
ramatuelle et de ramatuelle il ya un
festival sacha guitry à dax troisième
festival non la langue locale fait
j'avais région donc je viens jouer la
pièce et ouais avec mon père avait
raison aux prêts
à dax d'un grand hôtel grand hôtel où
aller sacha guitry si c'est que matane
et ces femmes là il s'ennuyait tellement
il disait elle s'ennuie tellement comme
ça l'on peut faire l'amour toute la
journée c'est bien c'est joli dites moi
on peut dire votre âge alors oui 67 ans
vous êtes vachement bien pour votre âge
oui et au lit je suis un jeune homme un
jeune homme qu'elle est quel est votre
secret jean claude brialy en secret
c'est que je crois que j'aime les autres
et que je dors bien voilà je crois que
quand on aime les autres vous savez il
ya une très belle phrase arletty elle
disait la meilleure crème de beauté
c'est la bonne conscience et quand on
sent dans le soir en ayant fait ce qu'on
devait faire de ce travail qu'on a été
sincère et qu'on a essayé de donner la
main alors l'autre on dort bien nommé
vous entendez l'aï meilleures crèmes de
beauté c'est la bonne conscience elle a
pas besoin de crème de beauté des
ravissantes
mais attends mais j'ai quand même le
droit de dire que la demoiselle est
ravissante là mais je pense à
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu